[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez des enfants de 6
ans ou est-ce que vous avez des
souvenirs de lorsque vous aviez six ans
laissez moi raconter vous raconter une
histoire il était une fois un petit
garçon qui se cachait dans une caverne
parce que le village où il habitait
avait été brûlé par de méchant dragon sa
maman était morte dans l'incendié et son
papa avait disparu dans sa grotte il
était entouré de dragons et d'ossements
humains
il ne lui restait que la couverture
laissé par son papa
un jour il entend une étoile qui
l'appelle et qui lui demande de la
suivre
alors il quitte sa grotte
il laisse sa couverture et il suit les
toiles sur la route il rencontre un
écureuil un blaireau et tous trois
suivre l'étoile
quand l'étoile va doucement il marche
doucement et quand elle va vite il court
chemin faisant il rencontre aussi le
retrouve le frère de son papa qui est
caché derrière une maison et qui lui
aussi va les aider dans leur quête
quelques dragons de la grotte les
suivent
mais à distance ils marchent tous
ensemble et un jour il arrive dans un
paysage magique c'est magnifique tout
brille dans ce paysage il ya un grand
arbre sommet duquel est caché un trésor
l'enfant sait qu'il va devoir rattraper
ce trésor
la tâche est rude le trésor est très
haut
bien sûr il pourrait utiliser l'écureuil
qui peut grimper facilement aux arbres
mais ce n'est pas ça l'idée ce serait
tricher c'est lui qui doit attraper le
trésor
il y à un autre obstacle un arbre très
grand à côté une sorte de gardiens qui
veillent sur le trésor il sait que
l'étoile va l'aider mais il ne sait pas
encore comment
[Musique]
et puis tout à coup ils voient de cet
arbre gardien une branche qui monte
monte dangereusement vers le soleil et
tout brûle
puis la neige arrive et se met à tout
nettoyer
c'est la fête le petit garçon a retrouvé
le trésor il n'a pas encore retrouvé son
papa mais il sait maintenant qu'il va
réussir sa quête avant de repartir ils
regardent tous ensemble le paysage
désolé mais une coupe verte descend d'un
arbre et l'enfant sait que tout va
repousser avant de repartir également il
va voir l'un des dragons et lui dit tu
ne veux pas nous aider et nous suivent
dans notre qu'être marcher avec nous et
le dragon acceptent ils repartent tous
ensemble
guidés par l'étoile qui est de plus en
plus belle et qui les mène jusqu'au papa
du petit garçon à la fin le roi des
dragons lui-même regarde les
retrouvailles de ce petit garçon de son
papa et de son oncle alors l'histoire
que je viens de vous raconter c'est
celle de teddy un petit garçon de 6 ans
teddy a travaillé avec moi pendant 12
semaines à raison d'une séance d'une
heure par semaine
il a simplement dessinée en écoutant une
musique au fort pouvoir évocateur il a
raconté ce qu'il dessinait vous allez
voir ses dessins j'ai oublié de mettre
ma diapositives avant vous allez voir
ses dessins c'est le parcours d'un héros
c'était étonnant de voir la continuité
de son histoire parce que teddy n'a revu
ni ses dessins ni son histoire d'une
séance à l'autre et ce durant trois mois
on a tous les ingrédients du compte on a
d'abord l'épreuve initiale avec l'
incendie qui brûle tout puis puis
l'enfant qui se retrouve seul dans sa
grotte sans père ni mère ensuite
viennent les alliés qui lui donne la
force de s'engager dans sa quête l'allié
principal c'est l'étoile qui va le
suivre tout au long de son parcours et
qui va le mener au centre de lui même
l'allier l'étoile c'est son guide
intérieur c'est sa part lumineuse
c'est la partie vous avez vu dans son
histoire comme il veille à se mettre à
l'écouté
j'adore ces phrases des enfants un ski
et ses textos quand l'étoile marche
doucement il se met à l'ecoute de la
partie de lui même
celle qui sait mais il ya aussi des
adversaires
les dragons vous avez observé qu'il n'en
a pas peur malgré leur aspect
destructeur au contraire il veille à les
intégrer au fil de son histoire et ce
faisant les dragons deviennent des
alliés qu'ils aident également dans sa
quête
alors là aussi une autre formule que
j'adore en travaillant avec son dragon
il me regarde me dit
les dragons c'est un peu un truc de
légende il redessine il lève la tête
mais les légendes
c'est un peu vrai aussi après les
dragons moment important dans l'histoire
c'est l'ultime épreuve qui va permettre
aux héros de se qualifier comme tels
regardez ce dessin numéro 7
ce dessin nous fait penser à l'histoire
de jason hill la conquête de la toison
d'or
la toison d'or était elle aussi au
sommet d'un grand arbre et les ty elle
était gardée par un dragon
mais jason n'a pas tuer le dragon en un
combat héroïque il l'andorre grâce à un
filtre préparé par m'aider oui il
obtient la toison d'or
mais malhonnêtement par la russe or
teddy a précisé qu'il ne voulait pas que
son héros utilise l'écureuil c'est lui
qui doit atteindre le trésor gage de la
réussite de sa quête
l'enfant se faisant aborde aussi les
éléments difficiles
son ombre il n'a pas peur d'exprimer ses
conflits ces tensions sa volonté
puissance jusqu'au moment où la neige
vient tout nettoyer donc ce faisant dans
ce parcours de héros et bien teddy
réussi sa quête et les trois figures
masculines sont réunis le pape à l'oncle
l'enfant alors je suis sûr que vous vous
demandez pourquoi il n'ya que des
figures masculines dans ce comté vous
vous dites oh là là là tu es ce un
moment on est sur un plan symbolique
l'enfant avait besoin de recettes de se
reconnecter avec ce principe masculin
qui lui manque tant dans sa croissance
en effet les parents de teddy ont
divorcé il y a deux ans et le système de
garde fait qu'il voit très peu son papa
et donc il exprimait il n'arrivait pas
exprimé que son papa lui manquait c'est
donc une étape importante pour lui
d'avoir réussi à poser ce cheveu ce
cheminement de réclamer son papa pour 5
croissance psychique
autre point important pour teddy c'est
qu'il
il avance il donc il nous montre le
parcours l'importance d'aider les
enfants à découvrir leur monde intérieur
ça n'est pas quelque chose d'inutile
c'est quelque chose d'important parce
que l'univers intérieur recèle des
qualités des ressources cachées des
trésors qu'il faut aider à révéler pour
affronter le réel
le dessin est un média magique pour
aborder les conflits ainsi les parents
autour des dessins ont pu parler et
trouver des solutions et des stratégies
pour aider teddy dans sa croissance
ainsi si teddy doit passer par une phase
d'apprentissage parce que la maman a
consulté en plus de ces problèmes donc
son papa divorcé il était colérique il
était inquiet il avait du mal à se
connecter aux autres et surtout il
répétait en boucle à chaque situation de
stress on m'en demande trop c'est trop
difficile donc la maman chercher des
solutions pour apaiser son enfant et
donc ça nous ramène à cette nécessité de
la façon dont nous nous occupons de nos
enfants et de l'importance en fait en
tant qu'adulte d'aider les enfants à
donner un sens à leur vie
pour teddy ayant fait ce parcours et
s'étant libéré puisque à la fin il aller
vers les autres il s'est fait des
copains
il pleurait - il a bien voulu participer
à un sport collectif
donc il ne sera pas identifié un
symptôme le simple même s'il doit passer
par une phase de rééducation
le symptôme ne sera pas un dragon
destructeur qui menace tout son
équilibre
ce sera simplement un élément un point
faible sur lequel on veut on pourra
trouver des solutions pour grandir se
construire l'enfant a besoin de paix
l'enfant et il en paie lorsque les
enseignants et les parents cherche à
déceler
dès leur plus jeune âge d'éventuelles
faiblesses sans quoi dit on leur
parcours scolaire et leur parcours de
lui sera forcément handicapé l'enfant et
il en paie lorsque la famille l'école
devienne un lieu de stress moi je trouve
qu'ils ont bien raison c'est petit
garçon ces petites filles de se révolter
de se rebeller
imaginez la tension oppressante
lorsque l'enfant est vécue comme un
problème à la maison à l'école
nous avons une responsabilité en tant
qu'adulte les études les parents les
éducateurs celle d'aider nos enfants à
grandir
si nous regardons nos enfants comme un
problème ils vont s'identifier à ce
problème et se vivront comme un problème
si au contraire on les regarde comme un
être en formation avec un potentiel a
révélé et sur la confiance en leurs
ressources intérieures
ils auront confiance en eux avec l'
envie de grandir de se construire de
s'ouvrir au monde qui les entoure alors
avec noël qui approche si riche en
symboles je vous propose de vous
questionner sur le sens que vous donnez
à vos vies je vous propose de réfléchir
et de créer un espace de paix pour
donner à l'eau à vos enfants n'ont pas
l'envi d'avoir mais celle d'être je vous
souhaite à tous en famille de parler de
l'esprit de noël de partage et de
dessiner toutes les raisons
d'émerveillement de vos existences
car comme l'a dit est dit c'est un peu
des légendes tout ça mais c'est un peu
vrai aussi
[Applaudissements]